Karen and I are still very very close
but as far as anything else you just
have to wait and see yeah the wait is
over Little People Big World Star Matt
Roloff and Karen Chandler are engaged we
have a plan that when all the stars
align just right we will both know it
and those Stars aligned just months
later Matt says after six wonderful
years together I asked Karen to marry me
and she said yes this is one of a kind
right here I landed him he's very very
amazing
quote we are looking forward to a simple
but elegant wedding in 2024 we're
totally committed to each other and we
do we we talk about our one year plan
our two-year plan our Five-Year Plan so
Matt was previously married to Amy
Roloff after going their separate ways
in 2015 she tied the knot with Chris
Merrick
[Music]
[Applause]
meanwhile Matt and Karen started dating
in 2017. they actually met on Roloff
farms Zach and Tori have really isolated
themselves you know from me and Cha-Cha
and that Farm's been at the center of a
family Rift that's played out on the
reality series I'm just here to support
Matt and support the whole process that
at some point everybody can just come
together this whole thing has been
painful the fact that it's still going
on is heartbreaking Karen tells other
people that she's waiting for our Olive
Branch and that Olive Branch the dove
took it to another Island I don't know
thank goodness for Karen being very
open-minded with different my crazy mind
that goes all over the place things
always happen for a reason so it was led
in a different direction and I think
it'll be positive for a lot of people
and bottom line is it's not it still
stays in his family they're very
respectful and and welcoming and you
know and we try to be the same I mean it
is getting easier and one thing I've got
to say about the whole Roloff Clan
is that no matter what turmoil is going
on between Father and Son or in between
the siblings they put that aside for the
grandkids whether it's a birthday or any
other celebration all are welcome no one
is excluded and
I'm impressed with how well that they
handle that this is still family because
in the end we still got to stay
connected and be there for each other
and Zach's a grown man and with his own
family his own priority so you know I as
the father totally understand that we
have a wonderful family we love all of
our kids dearly she has wonderful family
so you just focus on all the good things
going on and you realize that how many
blessings we actually have
congrats to the happy couple
[Music]
foreign